INTHEBEGINNINGTHEREWASNOPUNCTUATIONLOWERCASELETTERSOREVENSPACESBETWEENWORDSTHEREALSOWASNOGRAMMATICALWAYOFDISTINGUISHINGWHENANIDEAHADFINISHEDANDANEWONEBEGUNITDIDNTHELPTHATTHEIDEAOFSTANDARDIZEDSPELLINGWASALSONOTATHINGATLEASTNOTASWEWOULDTHINKOFITREADERSWERELEFTTOMUDDLETHEIRWAYTHROUGHANYTEXTASBESTTHEYCOULDUNSURPRISINGLYUNDERSTANDINGWHATAPARTICULARWORKWASACTUALLYSAYINGONTHEFIRSTREADTHROUGHWASPRETTYWELLUNHEARDOFATTHISTIME
question-markThe earliest writings, which
were syllabic and/or logographic (think Mayan
and Chinese), had no need for either spacing
or punctuation, as each word was typically
self-contained in the symbol.
However, as previously demonstrated, the lack
of punctuation and spacing in alphabetic writing
made comprehension difficult; so hard, in
fact, that in ancient Greece it was a rare
feat for an individual to understand a text
they were reading the first time through and
the idea of reading out-loud to a group without
extensive practice beforehand was also not
something typically done.
Nonetheless, a few notable exceptions aside,
punctuation in the West didn’t really appear
until about the end of the 3rd century BC
when Aristophanes of Byzantium, head librarian
at the Library of Alexandria (see: What Really
Happened to the Library of Alexandria?), introduced
the precursors of today’s punctuation marks.
He suggested inserting dots to indicate where
a passage ended and the length of pause needed
when speaking a text (useful in aiding knowing
how much breath was needed for the following
passage).
This convention subsequently began to appear
in various Greek works and became, to some
degree, relatively standardized.
Interestingly, the Greek words that came to
be our comma, colon and period were not describing
their dotted punctuation marks themselves,
but rather the length of the piece of text
that was being set apart, to wit: a low mark
(hypostigme) denoted a “unit smaller than
a clause,” which was known as a komma; a
mid-high mark (stigma mese) distinguished
a clause or kolon; and a high mark (stigma
teleia) denoted an entire sentence, known
as a periodos.
The Greeks also introduced a mark to distinguish
paragraphs (paragraphos or gamma), and set
off quotations with diples.
Not everyone was a fan of these marks.
Given that their entire purpose was not syntactical
but, rather, elocutionary, many, like the
famous Roman orator Cicero (106-43 BC), scorned
such punctuation, noting things like when
and how long to pause for breath “ought
to be determined not… by a stroke interposed
by a copyist, but by the constraint of the
rhythm.”[1]
Thanks to the influence of the Romans, the
punctuation introduced by the Greeks languished
as the oral tradition of Rome dominated.
However, once Christianity began to spread
across Europe via written texts, its scribes
began punctuating again in order to try to
preserve the original meaning of the Word.
(As Lynne Truss famously notes, there is a
big difference between “eats, shoots & leaves”
and “eats shoots and leaves.”)
In addition, by the 7th and 8th centuries,
spaces between words were becoming more common
(and are said to have been invented, or at
least popularized, by Irish and Scottish monks
of this era who were tired of wrestling with
separating unfamiliar Latin words).
At the end of the 8th century, Charlemagne
is generally credited with the introduction
of lowercase letters after requesting that
the monk Alcuin develop a unified alphabet,
which ultimately included these.
(See: The Origins of the English Alphabet)
Aristotle printed by Aldus Manutius
With the rise of the printing press a few
centuries later, the numerous conventions
(and symbols) used in punctuation became a
bit of a problem for printers, something that
had not been as much of an issue when things
were simply written by hand.
Enter Aldus Pius Manutius, a prominent Italian
publisher and printer of the 15th century
who, besides famously introducing “pocket
editions” of Greek and Roman classic works
meant for mass consumption and relatively
inexpensive to purchase, also seems to have
been the first typographer to use the comma
and semicolon.
(He also helped develop italic type with the
help of Venetian punch-cutter Francesco Griffo.
Interestingly, Griffo seems to have met an
untimely end after he beat his son-in-law
to death with an iron bar and is presumed
to have been executed for this crime- after
being charged with this murder, there is no
further record of him.)
Aldus’ grandson, Aldo Manutius the Younger
(1547-1597) took over the family printing
business at the age of just 14.
Not long after, he codified the modern, standardized
use of comma, colon and period, publishing
a book on the subject in the early 1560s called
Orthographiae ratio (A System of Orthography).
In the book, Aldo built on the ancient Greeks’
minimal punctuation marks and designated that
the comma would separate phrases and clauses,
the colon would be used for lists, and the
“full point” (read: period) would denote
the end of the sentence.
Aldo also explained the uses of other basic
punctuation including the question mark, apostrophe,
exclamation point and quotation marks.
Aldo also explicitly noted that the purpose
of these marks was more than merely as a rhetorical
aid, but that such marks were necessary in
order to express and preserve meaning (as
previously identified by the Christian scribes
centuries earlier).
For English writers and printers, however,
while they did begin almost universally using
the marks Aldo had expounded upon, punctuation
remained widely thought of as primarily for
elocution, and authors including George Puttenham
in The Arte of English Poesie (1589) and Simon
Daines in Orthoepia Anglicana (1640) even
set out a standard for the proper use of a
comma, semicolon and colon as simply a “pause
of one unit . . . two units . . . and of three,”
respectively.
This began to change after the publication
of Ben Jonson’s English Grammar (1640) in
which he illustrated how punctuation could
help preserve an author’s original intention,
rather than just giving a guide to how to
read a text out-loud.
Well received, by the time of the Restoration
(1660), using punctuation for syntactical
purposes was finally common, and in fact,
by the 18th century, excessive punctuation
(such as placing a comma between every possible
phrase) had become a major problem.
Overuse of punctuation continued to some extent
through the late 19th century until lexicographers
Henry Watson Fowler and Francis George Fowler
published The King’s English (1906), which
called for far less and established the style
of “light punctuation” that endures to
this day.